من المحتمل أنك شاهدت مقطع فيديو مثل هذا
حيث يتم اجتياح الملايين من الأشخاص مثله على
الإنترنت بواسطة القطط في الصناديق،
ولكن لماذا يوجد عدد قليل جدًا من مقاطع الفيديو للكلاب في الصناديق، لقد
جلسنا مع أحد
خبراء CAD الأكثر تأهيلاً على
هذا الكوكب في هذه الأشياء  على موقع YouTube، أنا متأكد من
أنك على قناة CNN لمعرفة سبب
عدم حب القطط للصناديق والكلاب،
وأعتقد أن أحد الأشياء التي يجب أن
نتذكرها هو أن القطط هي نوع
مفترس وفريسة في نفس الوقت، لذلك بالنسبة
للصناديق الكرتونية للقطط  يمكن أن يكون
مكانًا لطيفًا للسلامة والأمان للاختباء والراحة
وأخذ قيلولة،
كما أنه مكان رائع كمين للسرطان كمين
للحيوانات المفترسة ويفضل
الجلوس تحت شجيرة والانتظار ببطء
حتى تتجول فريستها حتى تتمكن من ذلك.
يمكن
لصندوق من الورق المقوى بداخله أن يمسك بها بنجاح ويمكن أن يخدم
غرضًا مشابهًا ويوفر مكانًا لها أيضًا،
فوجود مساحة آمنة للقطة مثل
صندوق من الورق المقوى أمر ضروري لرفاهيتها، وقد
ثبت أن القطط
أقل توترًا وأقل توترًا أيضًا.
من المحتمل أن يصابوا بالمرض في
مكان المأوى الخاص بهم إذا تم تزويدهم
بصندوق لأنهم بحاجة إلى مكان يشعرون فيه
بالأمان والقدرة على إخفاء
أحد الأسباب التي تجعل القطط تحب
صناديق الورق المقوى كثيرًا هو أن الورق المقوى
عازل ويساعد القطط على عدم  تحتاج إلى
طرد أي طاقة إضافية للحفاظ على
درجة حرارة جسمها، وفي بعض الأحيان
يكون هناك سبب أبسط لأن القطط
تحب الصناديق وتحب أن تضغط على نفسها
في صندوق صغير، ولماذا
يكون مريحًا وممتعًا، فهي تحب ذلك،
القطط الكبيرة تحب الصناديق أيضًا
ربما ليس كثيرًا  الصندوق المتبقي عند
الانتهاء منه،
الكثير من الأشخاص لا يلبون
الاحتياجات البيئية لقطتهم، فهم
يحتاجون إلى زوايا وزوايا وزوايا، ويحتاجون إلى
أماكن للاختباء، كما تعلم في كل مرة تقوم فيها
أمازون بتسليم لماذا لا تعطي شيئًا
لقطتك لإثراءها،
نعود الآن إلى السؤال  لماذا
لا تحب كلابنا الصناديق بقدر
القطط، أليس لديهم نفس
استراتيجيات الصيد، ليس لديهم نفس الحاجة
للحفظ ومكان للاختباء،
بعض الكلاب تحفرها ولكن في الغالب أعتقد أنهم
يستمتعون بها  تمزيقهم ليس مجرد
شيء يخص الكلاب